- I wanna close that with something fun.
This is "#What I'm Liking."
(big band music)
(audience claps and cheers)
Last year, we hooked up
with a hip hop violinist
who had a special relationship
with the beluga whales
at the Mystic Aquarium in Connecticut.
He'd come by to perform for the
sea life. That's super cool.
Now, I wanna share another
special relationship
happening at the aquarium.
This is between a trainer
Courtney and Clara the sea lion
- Clara is a seven year old sea lion,
and she was rescued years ago
and has been here for
the majority of her life.
Now she just gave you a inside scoop
on highlighting the very close
relationship that we have.
Right, Peanut?
(Courtney laughs)
(audience claps and cheers)
- My gosh.
That's how I hug people.
I just like lean in and lay on them.
(laughing) That would be awesome.
We've got Courtney and
Clara on the line right now.
Courtney watches on
NBC Connecticut at two.
What's up.
(audience claps and cheers)
Great to meet you.
Oh, my gosh.
- [Audience] Aww.
So how did your tight-knit
relationship with Clara began?
Begin. What?
(audience laughs)
- So Clara is seven years old,
but she was rescued off
the coast of California
when she was under a year old.
The United States government
deemed her non- releasable,
which means that they'll
find her a permanent home
where she can be an
ambassador for her species.
Now, the number one reason
why we train our animals
under our care is for their husbandry
or their health behaviors.
So having Clara come and sit in my lap
or lay her head on my
shoulder is really important
because it highlights
the trust that we have,
and it translates for those
important health behaviors
such as voluntary
ultrasounds and radiographs.
(audience claps)
- Oh, my gosh.
This is adorable.
So she's also quite the
performer, right, at the aquarium?
- She is. So Clara participates
in our current show
called "Connecting with Conservation,"
where the whole point of it
is try and inspire guests
to lead and participate in the three R's
such as reducing, reusing, and recycling.
Now, Clara not only does
those behaviors during shows
but she also shows them outside.
So we're gonna see if she can show you
her fun vocal (indistinct).
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Or, can you show your dance moves?
- [Kelly] ♪ Get down, get down ♪
(laughing) Oh, my gosh.
(audience claps)
- Can you smile for them?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Thank you so much, Courtney and Clara.
Great job, Clara.
(audience claps and cheers)
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all, our
season-long partner,
Pilot Pin Makers of Friction,
the go-to race bull pin
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly and
just being rad like Clara.
So they're gonna give the Ocean Society
at the Mystic Aquarium $1000.
(audience claps and cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
Oh, my God.
I love Clara. Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much, Courtney,
y'all have a blessed day.